Tyra Banks is a groundbreaking model and
mogul and she has never backed down from
a controversy so there was plenty for us
to talk about we connected for an
exclusive conversation starting with
some of the decisions and comments she
made when she was the host of America's
Next Top Model
[Applause]
it were played back some clips from
America's Next Top Model that were older
clips where you asked everyone to darken
their skin you are going to be Native
American and eat Indian oh yes I
apologize for it cuz we put it out and
even me just watching it after I was
like little insane right I mean we felt
like our skins beautiful let's paint the
world our color and then we saw it and
were like oh no this excuses other
people to do this in a negative way so I
went on my talk show we did an entire
segment what we did wrong and we
apologized for it
I'm not everybody Sonic it involved a
really false accusation and a hurtful
accusation that the producers of
America's Next Top Model including
myself put the girls in blackface and
and I was like what you know and there's
a whole new generation of people that
didn't grow up with my show and didn't
see that also there was pushback on the
episode about Danny Abbott's and you
addressing the gap in her teeth do you
really think you can have a covergirl
contract with the gap in your mouth when
I look back at that episode I can cringe
and I cringe through it through the eyes
of today Tyra has an extra special treat
for you guys we're gonna send you guys
to an amazing dentist here in LA I
wanted what they talked about this and
apologized and said you know what I
shouldn't have done that but I felt the
need to apologize again because not
everybody saw that I also have this
mission to get the models as much work
as possible and at times this desire to
make sure that my girls got work made me
forget my mission of why I get up every
single day which is more important than
any damn magazine cover
Tyra's also weighing in on another
controversy Gabrielle unions allegations
of a toxic and racist work environment
at AG T an independent investigation
found there was no wrongdoing when you
were there how was it i I had a lot of
fun but of course I heard about all the
stuff after I left and you know my heart
goes out to Gabrielle Union and you know
and heard the able to like express her
truth I hope she's okay right now I
haven't really talked to her or anything
but I hope she's okay is it it sounds
pretty heavy these days Tyra's
quarantine at home with four year old
son York and her mom Carolyn they're
giving us a peek into what it's like to
watch TV with them on celebrity watch
party tonight on Fox well this is going
to eliminate a whole bunch of them do
you think how's the dynamic change
between y'all cussing me out why'd you
do it like that you know your son's
hairs all track
I need comb his hair no we're doing this
celebrity watch party show you know too
much blush do with that but the one
thing that is funny is that my mom is 71
but she's like crushing on everybody
that comes on TV oh like Liam Neeson oh
I'm like I'm on he can get it
[Music]